the Invictus games are underway this
morning in Toronto Prince Harry created
the sports competition for wounded
veterans he made his first public
appearance with his American girlfriend
Megan Markel over the weekend at the
opening of this year's games and
everybody was very excited to see them
together
Marco lives in Toronto the couple
reportedly met last summer
Jeff course in the Canadian City with
the story Jeff good morning good morning
parts of the city have been transformed
this morning more than 500 athletes from
17 different countries competing in 12
events overseeing all of its one prince
at Saturday's opening ceremony Prince
Harry sat next to First Lady Melania
Trump the princes girlfriend American
actress Megan Markel was four rows away
these games are getting plenty of
surrounding star power but it's the
athletes who were competing on the field
in Toronto like US Air Force Master
Sergeant Ben Siegel
there are some world-class athletes out
there so I'm gonna have to put forth
put my best foot forward if you will and
and get out there and do what I've
trained to do while working as a dog
handler in Afghanistan in 2011 sergeant
Siegle and his k-9 partner Charlie
encountered a landmine just outside
their base time seemed to slow down as
someone thing that the movies might get
right sometimes Charlie wasn't seriously
hurt but sergeant Siegle lost the lower
portion of his left leg for me the
choice was simple I had a goal I wanted
to walk I wanted to run I wanted to do
everything and the only way to get there
is to get up and go still on active duty
sergeant Siegle is looking to add to the
three medals he won at the Invictus
games last year my expectations for
myself are high and I'm not willing to
walk away from the from the field with
anything less and then go
sebastiana lopez ariana is also
defending gold as the only woman on the
US wheelchair rugby team i his careless
boys what are they gonna do flip me
bring it lopez Ariana was injured riding
a motorcycle off duty she lost most of
her right leg recovery required about
two years at Walter Reed thoughts on the
coma for about I don't know 36 days or
something like that and when I woke up I
was so happy I was like oh cool I'm
relaxed I thought I died so many of them
come from literally off the couch Aaron
Moffitt is a sports psychologist and the
head coach of Team USA what we want to
try to do is make this a part of their
everyday life we don't want them just be
you know active one day a year but we
want them to be active 365 days a year
we are standing in a square in front of
City Hall that now includes two tennis
courts and as you can see competition
continues nor the Invictus games run
through Saturday Jeff Glor there in
Toronto so glad to see you there
exercise and sports can help heal many
things yeah